this
mindset in america in the western world
is a sickness
it is deviant and we do not want it
i'd like to take a minute to discuss the
harsh reality that black content
creators face i recently lost out on a
five figure brand deal for posting this
picture
with this caption
nowhere in the contract were there any
stipulations given around what kind of
content i could post except for the
branded content which would be approved
by the company they're posting that
picture and posting that caption i
received a phone call from my agent
saying that the company thought it was
inappropriate when i read that caption i
read a playful articulation of the love
i have for my man yet again when i look
at this picture i see playfulness i see
a black girl living her best life having
fun there's nothing inappropriate about
it to me especially not in the world we
live in today for centuries black
women's bodies have been scrutinized
they've been picked apart they've been
deemed unworthy they've been deemed
inappropriate and this is yet again an
extension of that rhetoric it's the
hyper-sexualization of the black female
body
okay you said a lot of things that were
right i mean
your contract never stipulated anything
about that
uh you don't find it inappropriate but
they do now i'm going to give you that
one though
black women have been uh
they have been stigmatized with their
bodies and stuff like that but where you
lost me is when you talk about over
sexualizing it's a booty pic
in the neck you look like a whole bag of
oranges delicious oranges though but
that's your booty being out
i mean we can see the puny prince right
here between the legs you hear that
whenever you talk about the over
sexualization of the female body
that's you
that's not that that's not me i didn't
put you in those fishnets i mean half of
the picture is your booty and i'm not
mad at it
whoopty woo but when you say that oh yes
because of that
the argument is a bit soft but go ahead
i'm sorry go ahead
hey man i just think people are allergic
to accountability [ __ ] can be
out here with their whole balls hanging
out they goddamn boxers walking around
the streets
this ain't outrageous all i see
is body parts taking some fresh air you
got to air it out when i read that
caption i read a playful articulation of
the love i have for my man you want to
show appreciation for your boyfriend
send him a picture in private
what the [ __ ] does the internet have to
do with your appreciation for your
boyfriend
[ __ ] are you dating instagram
uh are you in a committed relationship
with it's complicated it's instagram
what are you so deep in the metaverse
you [ __ ] somebody in vr what's going
on oh uh no no no
zero accountability
a hundred percent this is a facebook
post i would just like to take this time
to uh
uh wish happy birthday to my boyfriend
like i love you
i really appreciate you you're the best
and
you were in the same bed this morning
you're gonna go to the same bed at night
talk to your boyfriend there's some
[ __ ] that make posts about
[ __ ] that don't even have
facebook or instagram or social media
you know what i mean but i understand
why they say it's a flex you're flexing
your relationship you're not saying
happy birthday or this you're flexing
you're still with the [ __ ]
that's what you're doing that
[ __ ] got a phone sent him the
picture i appreciate you here's your
booty pic no you're flexing the only way
someone else could deem this as
inappropriate is if they projected their
sexual desires onto me
if you decide to leave their home
and you have made a effort
um
to dress in a manner that would indicate
that you are
how should i see this if you are taking
the time to
dress in a manner that says that you are
a homeless
okay okay yeah yeah you have dirt all
over your clothes and you're sleeping on
the sidewalk yeah you're fine and then i
come to you and i say sir can i help you
and you go oh my
friends for what reason do i look like i
need help yeah it's like it's like a
good analogy that i don't even know
remember who said that no no like if i
dress like a cop
if i dress like a cop i can't be mad
that people ask me for help yes i'm the
one who told you this one the knowledge
has entered your cranium finally
yeah repeating the words that i've said
to me
no because i heard i heard a comedian
and it was not you [ __ ]
i i'm quite certain i am a comedian
every day i spread the knowledge with
you laugh yeah it's not you it was me no
you took it from somewhere
yeah you are accusing me of theft after
you have stolen from me no i i i said
you are noah you are truly impressive
huh you have engaged in plagiarism by
plagiarizing me because you have accused
me of a pleasure
it
you are also incapable of accountability
no i am i said it was not it's okay hey
this is the western world
they come here they say hey i'll take
your money
but i don't want to pay tax
this one he's going to jail for sure
where's three snipes
yeah i'm going to jail yeah i go to jail
all right that one i do in that evening
what the [ __ ] is going on
yeah receiving calls yeah yes yes it is
the police
you are going to jail
you are avoiding accountability
so we are looking at this one huh shall
say oh you are looking at me you are
projecting your sexuality my friend you
have projected your sexuality onto my
eyes you are the one who had decided to
live in your underwear and then
projected your skin onto my vision i did
not leave and then imagine you doing
something you have done it and i have
seen you doing it and then you are mad
at me for seeing you doing it and then
when i say you have done it you are
saying the papaya look at this one he is
a shameful individual for what reason i
have simply left my abode and observed
the world and you are upset at me for
what you have made me observe
you have told me that i am ugly i have
been upset by the fact that you have
said i am ugly and then you are saying i
projected my negative negative feelings
on you
this
mindset in america in the western world
is a sickness
it is deviant and we do not want it
this is why i'm going to return to
africa we are going to enjoy the good
fruit
because these women here's a vampire
they are lost
they are so lost look at this one she
has left the home huh she has taken off
her shirt look look she took it off
and she said for what reason are you
looking at me at my titties at my chest
look it is my nipple
for what reason you are projecting your
eyesight onto me
no no no no i'm so tired no my friends
we are going to we are going to have a
conversation we are going to have a
i heard someone knocking at the door it
is a police you are going to jail
he is going to jail this one
it's been generally agreed upon by the
black community for decades that the n
word isn't derogatory it's a term of
endearment if you want to use the n word
congratulations there's plenty of black
people who won't want to work with you
because you use the n word oh yeah
this whole idea like it's a term of
endearment that's between you and some
black folks a lot of other black folks
disagree there's folks who say
i will not support what you do because
you say [ __ ] that we and you know what
i mean
you know what i say what you say
cool
i'm mad at you you're entitled to your
opinion
and i'm gonna get mad at a company who
don't want to work with me for the same
reason why
i use the word and i accept the
responsibility and the consequences that
come with it accountability
what's that when people say i wanna
subscribe do you know what you know what
i don't say
i'm just showing appreciation to my
[ __ ]
if i get commissioned by a suit company
right they're talking about above listen
we like your style we want you to come
on and and fashion some of these suits
five figure deal i'm like great the next
day i'm out here popping bottles with
[ __ ] in in instagram videos blinged
out gold chain they may not think that
my brand is going to benefit their brand
and so they don't want the association
between those two things even if it's
not written in the contract by the way
that's it
right if you want to be a preppy
[ __ ] some rap labels won't want
to [ __ ] with you they say you too corny
that happens
it's like [ __ ] want to get up
here and do anything and then have
everyone be yes queen
you say yet again when i look at this
picture i see playfulness i see a black
girl living her best life oh go go live
your best life
mind is these five figures and you know
there have been people that don't want
to mess with us people that don't want
to be here yeah
people in our dm's dropping i really
don't have in the comments in the in the
dms and in the comments i don't really
appreciate you think that they say that
to us
i'm pretty sure that we lost
opportunities and people don't come to
us with with uh advertisement and stuff
like that we we lose out on
advertisement we do we do because we
don't want to budge we don't want to ban
we don't want to do this and that in the
third
we live our best life but we live with
the consequences we've lost homies we've
lost work opportunities we've lost
uh collapse you want to talk about
homies we lost well i mean you
especially jesus you know my circle been
tight fine but it's fun but it's but i
live with the consequences and i
understand that what i did what i did is
no i didn't do like and i can explain to
that person i did that not because of
how you see it because of how i see it
we agree to disagree we part ways and
it's not good it's all good
[ __ ]
it's all good but you have you
you just lost me at hypersexuality and i
was like no that's you you did that
and it's really funny she lost me before
yeah i know no she lost me
i saw your face i was i was giving it
time because i know there was something
that was about to come but i know she
like she lost you before i know you
wanna know why she lost me before go
ahead because once i see the picture i'm
like yeah i could see companies not
wanting to work with you yeah so once
you start paddling off and crying about
the fact that like oh my god uh systemic
no
don't bring
people's plight into your own bad
decisions you know what i mean a
[ __ ] want to go and smack
somebody in the face to talk about well
dude a systemic racing the way i've
learned to engage with other people's
conversations to punch no [ __ ] you just
made a bad decision don't put that on
black people you get what i'm saying
that's you you cannot please everybody
no you can't it's impossible
it's impossible you want to have all
that freedom it's gonna it's gon it's
absolutely gonna come with [ __ ]
not liking you and that's why when i
walk in the street and you come say
what's up start with hey what's up
preacher i like what you do because i
don't know what you want and i'm gonna
be on guard
right
i don't know what you want cause there's
[ __ ] that out there that don't
like what we do they hate what we do and
you know what it's fine because as much
liberty as i have they have too and
these people don't have the liberty not
to want to work let me ask a question
let me ask a question are we really
sitting here i'm just curious this is my
mama okay a girl posted a picture of
herself in a nice dress yeah cool all
right a girl sits there a ass bent over
crotch facing the camera her head in the
background take whatever picture you
want i don't care my point being
i think some people are just completely
oblivious to how they come across to
other people when they do in these
pictures
people gonna look at you and be like you
know you're on your thought [ __ ] doesn't
mean it's true doesn't mean it's not but
that's how they gonna interpret that
picture when you out here with your
crotch facing the camera and [ __ ]
fishnets and your thong how is anybody
supposed to look at you and say that
don't look a little bit tactless that
don't look a little bit thirst trappy
right that's their scrappy all right
it's it's more than just thirst trapping
i'm trying to be polite [ __ ] i'm not
i'm not that's my point i think people
need to be told i'm trying to please
everybody
they need to know because i think
there's women out here who are
delusioned about how it is like try to
hold up let me ask you do you guys
really think you can work in a
professional setting
and do that
white or black is it that what's
considered appropriate or professional
is always adjacent to whiteness you want
the activist part of me that's
articulate and intelligent but that's
just one side of my black girl magic but
that's just one side of my black girl
magic
because the other side of me knows how
to turn up and throw this ass and that's
what i'm gonna do we don't have to
separate who we are in order to please
these companies we don't have to erase
or hide any aspect of our personality
and you don't have to separate who you
are
but not everybody's gonna deal with you
it's okay
but i feel like there's a little bit of
undertone of you being mad
you being mad because you lost the money
and i can understand it's it's wack to
lose money the potential money because
you already saw where you would have
planned it but yeah let me say this some
of you [ __ ] need a diary some
you guys need to go up to your friends
if you want to shake your ass shake your
ass with them not everybody got to be
for the internet i got a different side
to me offline that i don't share with
everyone else guess what if i show it to
everyone else maybe not everyone would
love it you're allowed to keep things
for yourself there's plenty of women who
are out here being classy to some degree
and behind closed doors they get freaky
and nasty with it
you don't have to show everything to
everyone
hey man i got a big dick but they don't
they need to know all the sides of me
they can cook no
just like just cause you got it don't
mean you gotta flaunt it and if you
decide to flaunt all aspects of you
don't be mad with some people i actually
didn't like that part of you i think
that people have misunderstood the whole
concept of like
being authentic online
being authentic online does not mean
that you share every part of yourself
unreserved
that's not what it means
it means that the parts of you that you
do share you share that in a way that
really represents who you are that's